The joe rogan experience.
What is the state of Japanese on my main now?
It was gigantic for awhile when Soccer Rabo was big.
When you were huge.
When pride was filling 90,000 seat arenas.
Huge.
It was like nothing else.
It's like I experienced 60,000 at Rogers in Canada when George Saint Pierre
fought Jake shields.
I couldn't imagine 30 more thousand people there.
But you were there for that.
It was awesome.
I mean if that was a 10 and before,
I mean may actually came out when they were only had pancreas and that was a
one,
it sounded like a foreigner right now what happened is Yuck was the involvement.
Uh,
I mean the thing that people don't realize is in Japan,
everything is Jaquelle's involvement.
Every big company,
every big promotion shoot,
they'll chose to say that didn't ever get a cause Yahoo's involvement.
But they're there.
They're backed by [inaudible],
which is the second largest group of Japan,
you know,
so everyone has yakuza connections to any big Coca Cola company.
Johnson and Johnson.
Any company has yell cause the connections.
Wow.
But it's not public.
So save cocacola goes over there and they open up a plant in Japan.
They must go through the Yakuza.
They'll have that connections.
Yes,
definitely.
How do they negotiate that?
Well,
it's,
it's really easy.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
um,
it's a turf thing.
It's a,
if you know somebody,
it's,
it's a percentage you pay.
It's,
it's a,
it's pretty given thing.
It's almost like,
like taxes.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pink Tabs just accepted.
Accepted,
accepted.
That's why it's,
it's funny how when it became public,
everyone,
it got really bad because it's a,
it's a weird thing is accepted,
but it's frowned upon.
It's something that they know they need to be a part of in society,
but they don't want to make it public because the Yakuza has,
does have a bad name.
That was the only place where I've ever been with a,
asked me to cover up my tattoos.
Yeah.
It was weird.
That's why I don't have,
I try to keep them all from my sleep,
so it comes up from here.
But after that I stopped because I don't want to
walk around and you know,
be kicked out of places,
you know,
I just got denied to go in a hotel like last week when I was in Japan.
Really?
Yeah.
Because of my tattoos with the neck.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
they saw it.
They sell it for wear a Hoodie.
It covers it up.
It helps me.
Yeah.
I got a,
I got kicked out of a gym.
They made me go put a long sleeve shirt on.
The Gym's even big gyms at Gold's gym won that year.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
What does it represent to Japanese?
It represents the underworld gangsters and you know the,
you got to figure when you have a gang,
a gang,
there's two or three top men.
Those men are awesome people.
And then you got the rest of the hundreds and thousands that are punks and
that's the ones that you see.
So basically a,
a gangster,
someone with tattoos,
which equals the Alcazar would mean trouble and they would,
if you go into a sports gym and you're working out next to a guy and you know
you're,
you're working on,
say you take his awaits by accident because see in the middle of a set and if
you're doing it to someone that's a normal person,
he'll just say,
hey,
I was using ways old.
Sorry.
Okay,
well it might be different for the Yakuza and people would rather not work out
in the area if there's a cause.
The guy working on there,
so it's a bad rap.
I mean it's just justifiable though.
I can understand that.
The UFC,
when they went in and bought pride,
it's kind of a crazy story,
but they paid $65 million.
They bought pride and they thought,
you know,
hey,
we're going to run pride as well as the UFC.
The same way they did with Strikeforce when they bought strike force,
they kept strike for us going for a years.
They thought they were going to do that.
But meanwhile it turned out all the contracts are illegal.
They really didn't have anybody on the contract.
They spent $65 million and all they really got was a video library.
And then while they had offices in Japan and they were hiring these people and
painful him,
they were starting up dream.
They were starting up their own organization,
organizing everything and yeah.
And then,
you know,
the UFC,
it took years before they could come back and do a UFC there.
They took,
it took a long time.
Dana was getting like some like underworld threats and you know,
yeah,
that's what I heard.
And I,
sorry,
I sent Dana email in that because if anything,
I have a lot of pulling that site and I told him that if you have any problems
with that,
I can help you.
What would he have to do,
come to you and then you go to the,
I really respected in their world.
So,
um,
I could,
I,
if I don't know the person directly,
I have guys at norm.
So if he had any type of problem,
I still,
it still sounds still today,
if Dana has any type of underwrote problems there,
if he calls me arc,
take care of it for him.
It's interesting that there's such an underworld presence in Japan because it
seems so safe when you're there.
Everything is so,
people are so polite and you don't see violence you don't see like you see drunk
people walking into the street and no one hurts them day.
Everyone's fine.
Girls Walk down the dark lanes and it's okay.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah.
It's a strange sort of,
you know,
a contrast.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's,
it's almost like you just have bad areas.
Like can change your cool.
They have over 300 was offices there.
Roppongi only has three.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you've got,
these are districts that they're accumulated in,
they have offices,
they have offices.
Yeah.
The mafia doesn't have office.
See that's the thing.
Like for me,
I guess I grew up in America,
so for me the mafia just scares me way more.
I mean,
I have this image that you screw with the Mafia.
You better change your name,
you were to move and you better hide who your family is and you've got to get
the hell out of just disappear.
But when you get in trouble at the Yakuza,
um,
I've been in trouble with them before and it's,
it's,
it's like you can kind of pretty much deal with them the way you want to deal
with them.
You know,
it depends on how much you're willing to sacrifice.
Yeah.
And for me it was your issue with them.
There was a one to it with kid.
Um,
when,
when I,
this guy,
this Jaquez guy wanting to,
to open up a gym and I agreed to open up a gym with him called purebred Tokyo
killer bee.
And I just told them that the only thing you have to do is you have to hire two
of my fighters so they can make a living through fighting.
And I wanted to help them on,
I want to no money,
you can use my name or my gym,
but you have to hire my two fighters.
He,
they acquired kid and they're hard.
Ryan Bull.
And those are the fighters in everything was good.
And what happened was kid started,
um,
I guess from the influence of his father,
he started being,
the loyalty issue in him was getting,
was wavering where he wasn't telling me stuff,
he was hiding stuff.
He's lying to me.
And then I put that [inaudible] was the guy in charge of them that ran the gym.
So I told him,
I called him and say,
what's going on man?
You got to take care of it.
He goes,
I'll take care of it.
I'll take care of.
He's told me that and it got to a point he didn't take care of it.
So I called him and I was pissed dirty by now.
And I called him and said,
you know what?
Call me.
He avoided my calls for three days.
So three,
three,
three weeks.
And I'm sitting there,
this guy's running from me.
I'm thinking this is ridiculous.
So then they'll say,
this guy is running from me.
I'm not going to look for him.
I want to,
he's going to pop up these guys that charter to run their pop up all the time.
You know,
so I'm sitting there watching the [inaudible] kid flight and kid wins a fight
and this guy's in the ring jumping and hug him and team has a mother fucker.
This guy's hiding from me and he's on national TV hugging me saying Hansen,
I'm here.
So I guess is it?
So I called my students,
I took the final where the after party is what after part and I was leery going
to walk in there and grab that guy with the hair and pulled the model of party.
But my students felt it was going to be a problem,
is going to make too much commotion.
The cops are going to be called.
So Daddy said to get them in.
They brought him up and brought him to the park and pretty much beat him for
like 20 minutes,
which is something he shouldn't do in Japan because in the acquisition world
they work by face,
they work by being tough,
being scary to collect money and stuff.
And if he's got all,
they got a black tie and bruises on their faces,
kind of goes against the fact that they're tough people.
You know?
So I beat him up pretty bad.
And,
um,
I did.
But see,
the thing is I never did pick on anyone.
I never did do anything without a reason.
And I,
I believed that I would die for my beliefs tomorrow and I believe that I was
right and this guy really deserve that shit.
So if they didn't like it,
if the top guys didn't like it,
then they can,
they know where to find me.
And so what happened was it was going off for 20 minutes.
And when I went down,
I let people in,
some people in my friends know and they were all worried.
So they made calls and we had two other Yakuza guys come down to the scene to,
to try and stop me,
to kind of getting me tween not stop me physically,
but to,
to,
to ask for forgiveness for this guy.
And they're kind of like bawling in the middle of me and the guy and I'm getting
around and just,
just giving them wax at a time.
And when he,
if he would've fallen from a hit,
I had ground and standing right back it up.
Yeah.
So it's kind of getting really,
he was all bloody and then,
um,
these guys are kind of my friends too,
so they weren't going to get involved,
but they're trying to stop me from going too far.
And when we,
there's this old lady,
you know how you have the old ladies in the neighborhood that don't give a fuck
who you are.
She,
this lady comes on and says screaming at us,
he didn't make it the less noise and shit cause that gets on the lady and I say,
no,
no.
Hey Man,
don't do that man.
Let's go.
So he moved over to the next part and as you're moving on with the next bar,
lake three fricking monkeys disguise higher ups to find out what's happening and
come out and they're walking up like these,
you know,
like the movies they are walking through that I,
it was funny because I call them monkeys because they're walking through bushes.
I saw him walking through the trees and they came on and like,
Oh shit,
these are the guys,
these are like the hot head guys.
And they came up to me and they're screaming in Japanese to me,
Oh,
you were going to hurt you now because you heard our brother.
And then some of my guys came and held him back and I say,
okay,
wait a minute.
If it's going to happen,
it's going to have to know.
So I told my guys,
let 'em go.
I said,
let him go.
I just want to say one thing to you guys.
And they,
they came up and they're all there,
you know,
they got this,
this stance and they're all mad at me and looking at me and I'm the to see,
I got one thing to do.
If I got one thing to say,
if I say you don't like it,
we can have it all.
I said,
I'm ready to die tonight.
And then this guy goes,
okay.
And so I tell them,
okay,
if someone fucked you over,
I sent you wanted to punish them.
Wouldn't that be fair?
He goes,
yes,
but look what you did to him.
Look at him,
the kid,
he's all blood,
he's standing here are bloody and owner.
And I said,
well,
you know what?
Let's put it this way.
I said,
I'll shoot one question if going to kill him with my hands.
How fast you think I could do it?
He said,
probably five minutes within five minutes.
I said,
hell,
within two minutes I killed that fucker.
And he goes,
yeah,
but what do you do?
What does that mean?
And I said,
well,
I ain't even hitting him for 20 minutes.
I said,
dude,
this is,
this is like 10% of what I could do.
And I said,
don't you agree?
If you what you,
if you had somebody fuck you over and you decide to just to 10% out of respect
to the people behind him,
wouldn't you think that's fair?
And they guy just changed.
Straight up.
Bull stopped and he said,
you're right man.
Thank you.
Wow.
That doesn't fly in America.
That's,
that's an interesting interesting code.
The they believe in the underworld side is there's two sides of the fence,
the legal side,
the illegal side,
the legitimate site and you are never ever,
if you're on the ligament side,
they have a legitimate problem.
You are never ever allowed to go to the other side to get home.
You're,
you're,
if you're going to stay,
you're going to get other guys to help you on this site and retaliate,
that's fine.
But if you ever go to authorities and you lose face and you can never can ever
work in that world again.
So
wow.
So you have to deal with things on your own,
the problem like that.
Yeah.
You pretty much,
if you,
if you're someone from the outside and you're like a regular businessmen and
these guys come and bother you,
the best thing to do is go to the authorities because of the,
the police are just waiting to grab the yellow buses.
So He's psycho role.
It's like Kryptonite to the [inaudible].
If you go say you're going to the police still back off.
But if I,
I live my life in that side pretty much,
you know what I mean?
A lot of my friends are part of those groups and a lot of my beliefs run really
deep with their beliefs.
You know the,
I mean,
see the thing is,
is you,
you and you hear about the youngest,
they get a bad rap because you talk about child pornography,
drugs,
you know,
extortion.
Um,
what is that?
Uh,
when they,
when they steal money from people,
you know,
but the thing that they don't see that,
so that's all the things in the media,
but the things that they don't see,
which I feel is,
uh,
is really unfortunate is the honor and the loyalty they have for each other.
And that's where me and them click really well.
You know what I mean?
They will die for anyone in your group tomorrow.
They'll go to jail for 10 years for their boss tomorrow if they have to.
I mean,
you don't see that type of loyalty around all these,
you know,
non American and I love,
I think that loyalty,
you know,
and they,
and that's,
I think that's why they respect me so much is you,
I will die for my values.
I'll die for my people that are close to me.
It's just such a
unbelievably fascinating culture.
How different Japan is.
And so many ways,
like a big,
there's big gaps in it.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's really,
really,
really fascinating stuff.
It's just that all these different cultures evolve independently,
that the Japanese culture evolved independently from the American culture.
We independently from the European culture and it's so different.
Yeah,
it is all he think all the places are different men.
It's hard to really move into,
uh,
a different country and,
and run yourself in the way that you learned in another country because it's,
you know,
I said,
well,
when in Rome he was,
what do you,
what do you think about the state of a Japanese MMA right now?
Because it's kind of in a transitionary period.
If one at one point in time it was gigantic and you say Yakuza involvement as
why people,
corporate sponsors backed out and then they lost a lot of viewership.
But man,
it was just not that long ago that there were selling out these gigantic places.
Not what,
what's going on right now?
Well,
right now I'm,
like I said,
it's up the number four right now.
There's people that are real hesitant.
They're not among many sponsors that want to put money into it.
Um,
on the flip side,
the big things that's happening is gangster events where they allow gangsters to
fight in the ring.
And yeah,
it's crazy though.
This thick,
I attend all of those.
I'm like a guest and most of them they pay me to just to be there and to judge
sometimes to make a speech in their ring.
Maybe in the beginning,
because I'm still respected in that world,
that to have me there a lot of these gangsters him down,
you know,
when they want to riot,
they don't riot,
you know?
I mean,
you go to the event and it's not unusual to see a picture of two stick figures
fighting and has a big x on it.
So don't fight,
don't fight.
It's like,
isn't that a given?
You never see any signs up in the UFC saying please don't fight in the audience.
It's like,
it's already given this,
not something you should do.
But yeah,
so that's a big thing right now.
But it's good because the gangster events actually they,
they have headbutts,
they have elbow striking that you can split system.
You can neither groin,
you can do whatever.
Pretty much they have two on one.
They have to and to really,
it's crazy dude.
How often do they have these findings held on the bowl?
Once a month man,
there's one somewhere.
Shit.
Yeah.
And it's like these guys,
it's become,
it's a good trend because it's become where these guys just came off the street
singing.
They're tough gassing on one minute from these guys actually spending time in
the gym though and being off the street.
So it's like I should a good movement.
Um,
a lot of,
there's about three or four gang shirts already now this actually made their pro
debut and deep.
So these guys are actually going to run the gangs and,
and start selling drugs and you know,
doing illegal activity.
They're not training and it's having a future and fighting,
which is awesome.
As far as the legitimate side of MMA,
I,
I see it,
I can see it picking up again and it's all due to the UFC.
The UFC has done a couple of events there now.
And the last one they did when I went to that,
it was,
it's huge man.
It's so big.
I mean,
as much as the Japanese fans are kind of losing hope in Japanese,
I mean maybe cause a lot of productions were folding.
Um,
when,
uh,
when we went to,
when I went to the UFC,
uh,
I felt debt that energy again when I was fighting in pride,
that energy that they had in the audience.
And especially when ramp piece chemo with the pride music,
it gave me goosebumps because when he came out to that,
I looked around the arena and I was like,
damn,
this is a psycho pride.
This is a,
this is a pride.
And I,
it's the first time since that big incident with the [inaudible] and pride that
I've actually seen that again.
It,
it's so surreal to me actually.
And I was like,
John,
this is gonna,
this is gonna be the,
the ticket back is the UFC coming to Japan.
If the UFC did an ultimate fighter in Japan and,
uh,
have a Japanese version of it,
would you be interested in coaching?
Oh yeah.
We'll definitely,
yeah,
I would love to.
That'd be perfect.
You'd be,
you would really be perfect for something like that.
I would love that.
You know,
[inaudible].